Vladimir Putin ha dicho que seguramente
tendrá que llegar en algún momento a
algún tipo de solución negociada
respecto a Ucrania pero se ha mostrado
bastante molesto con occidente que dice
que se está aprovechando de la situación
usando a los ucranianos como Carne de
cañón especialmente enfadado se
encuentra Putin con los gobiernos de
Francia y Alemania ha recordado que
estos dos países en el año 2014 y sobre
todo en 2015 ayudaron a forjar un alto
el fuego entre los separatistas
precursos apoyados por Rusia y el
gobierno de kiev y sin embargo en esta
ocasión lo que han hecho es dar más y
más armas al gobierno ucraniano también
ha hablado Putin del petróleo de las
fórmulas que está buscando ahora Moscú
para reaccionar a ese tope en el precio
al petróleo ruso ha dicho que es posible
que reduzca Rusia la producción Aunque
todavía no lo tiene decidido ha
confirmado que Rusia no va a vender
petróleo a aquellos países que apliquen
ese tope al precio de 60 dólares